(typewriter typing)
- Since @Midnight's in the
Big Apple, we decided to go
to our local Craigslist to
see what depraved perverts
are looking to hook up with,
and to help us read it,
we needed the most depraved
pervert we could find.
So please welcome to the
stage, Gilbert Gottfried.
(audience cheers)
(pulsing groovy music)
(audience and guests
applaud and cheer)
- Thank you, Gilbert.
- Thank you.
(audience laughs and whoops)
Yes!
(audience laughs)
It is true that I am
a depraved pervert.
(audience laughs)
But I'm also crushingly lonely.
Are any of you ladies
getting wet now?
(audience laughs)
(Bridget whoops)
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
That actually just
made my nose run.
(Gilbert, Bridget,
and audience laugh)
- I'll take it!
(audience laughs and claps)
Every time I try to
get close to someone,
I end up smothering them.
And by someone I mean
disenfranchised runaways.
(audience laughs)
And by smothering I mean
literally smother them to death.
(audience laughs and claps)
Sometimes I smother
them with a pillow.
(audience laughs)
Other times, slowly
with a piano wire.
(audience laughs)
But that's neither
here nor there.
- Sure, yeah.
That's not, really, we'll just.
- I am known to
peruse Craigslist
in my neverending pursuit
to find vintage end tables.
(audience laughs)
Or reasonably priced,
anonymous hand-jobs.
(audience laughs and whoops)
I found this post entitled,
Dragon Invades Chinatown.
- Oh?
What's it say?
- It reads,
"Sup, sup.
(Chris and audience laughs)
"This is Dragon,
"and I will invade Chinatown
like I did yesterday.
"IDK like the Asian
culture and Asian women.
(audience laughs)
"Only downside is,
"I'm a picky ass eater."
(Chris, guests,
and audience laugh)
Just for the record, I'm also
a picky ass eater, all right?
(Chris, guests, and
audience laugh and clap)
I will not eat a girl's asshole
unless it's gluten-free.
- Oh, sure.
(audience laughs and cheers)
Gilbert Gottfried.
- Yup, yup!
- Yup, yup.
Gilbert Gottfried, everyone.